monsieur le président
la séance est reprise même si la cloche
a du mal
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je souhaite tous mes vœux à tous ceux à
qui je les auraient pas encore souhaité
et comme vous êtes extrêmement nombreux
il y en a forcément à l'intérieur
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution proposant au
gouvernement de sortir le système
électrique des mécanismes concurrentiels
présentés en application de l'article 34
1 de la Constitution par Messieurs
Fabien gay Pierre Laurent Marie-Noël
linmann et plusieurs de leurs collègues
demandent de groupes cscrce dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Fabien gay auteur de la
proposition de résolution pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
jour après jour
l'impact des prix de l'énergie sur les
usages nos entreprises nos collectivités
territoriales donne avoir l'ampleur de
la crise qui est devant nous le mythe de
la libéralisation du secteur de
l'énergie et de ces mécanismes
concurrentiels qui devait faire baisser
les prix non pas passer l'épreuve de la
réalité ils n'ont pas protégé les
consommateurs et les consommatrices pas
plus que les économies européennes et je
pense qu'il faut être sur les faits
plutôt que sur les dogmes la proposition
que nous faisons aujourd'hui c'est de
sortir du marché européen de l'énergie
et de ce mécanisme de construction des
prix
de prendre un autre chemin que celle de
l'Europe du marché et des traders et de
construire ensemble une robe de
l'énergie qui réponde aux besoins
humains aux besoins vitaux à celle du
climat et qui protège les plus fragiles
des peuples européens et avant cela je
veux d'abord répondre à une
contre-vérité sortir du marché européen
serait sortir de l'interconnexion
européenne et le repli sur soi tout ceci
est Annonay par un certain nombre de
membres du gouvernement
problème
le marché européen a été créé en 1997 et
les premières interconnexions celle qui
a vu la France l'Allemagne et la Suisse
crée des interconnexions c'est
1967 je propose donc que nous arrêtions
de répéter dans nos nez cette
contre-vérité et que nous les laissions
aux experts des plateaux de télévision
de BFM Business et que nous nous
concentrons sur les faits tout comme
nous pouvons faire du commerce sans
traiter de libre-échange climaticides
puisqu'on commerce depuis l'Antiquité
nous pouvons maintenir les
interconnexions et les échanges
solidaires plutôt que de laisser les
traders faire du profit
mes chers collègues ce marché européen
ne peut pas fonctionner il repose sur
des illusions la première c'est que
l'électricité est une marchandise comme
une autre et qu'on pourrait donc
organiser de toutes pièces un marché ou
une offre rencontrerez une demande sauf
que marcher s'organise certes avec une
offre et une demande mais surtout avec
un stock si l'offre est supérieure à la
demande le prix est faible et
inversement sauf que précisément les dés
sont pipés sur le marché européen
l'électricité puisque le producteur doit
produire ce que la demande veut à
l'instant T vous pouvez donc vendre
votre électricité à 1 euro le
mégawatt-heure 10 100 ou 1000 la demande
devra l'acheter à ce prix là et de plus
les autorités régulatrices chez nous RTE
pourront toujours venir en secours au
dernier moment pour ajuster les besoins
s'il y a justement un risque cela ne
peut donc pas fonctionner d'autant plus
qu'avait le marché de gros et le marché
spot c'est un système qui favorise le
trading nous continuerons donc à dire
que l'électricité est plus largement
l'énergie parce qu'elles sont
nécessaires et vitales à la vie doivent
être sortis du secteur marchand et
reconnu comme un bien de l'humanité
j'aimerais ensuite revenir sur une
deuxième illusion on a donc un marché
européen mais plusieurs stratégies
nationales de production nationale c'est
comme si nous avions un marché européen
de l'électricité mais que certains
construiraient des Ladas doivent des
Twingo d'autres des Ferrari et d'autres
des Mercedes et qu'ensuite on met tout
ça sur le même marché et qu'on leur
donne le même prix vous me diriez c'est
impensable mais oui mais précisément
c'est ce que nous faisons sur
l'électricité car quel que soit le mix
electrique d'actionnal que vous soyez
aux énergies fossiles que vous auriez
sur les énergies renouvelables que vous
soyez sur l'hydraulique ou que si vous
soyez sur le nucléaire on fixe le même
prix au niveau européen avec le coût
marginal c'est un fonctionnement qui
s'entend dans une stratégie nationale
mais qui ne peut pas marcher sur un
niveau européen d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
le marché européen qui a créé le coût
marginal c'est Marcel Boiteux directeur
de cette grande entreprise qui fut EDF
de 1967 à 87 mais il avait raison parce
que ça s'entendait sur une stratégie
nationale mais c'est une aberration
lorsqu'on passe au niveau européen parce
que peu importe que l'on dépende peu du
gaz comme nous moins d'1% ou par le par
rapport aux Allemands à 40%, nous payons
le même prix et contrairement à la
promesse forte de départ
cela ne pousse pas les États membres à
décarboner leur stratégie de production
ou investir dans les énergies
renouvelables car quoi qu'il arrive et
même sans investissement vous paierez le
même prix que vos voisins ensuite la
troisième illusion le marché européen
mettra en lien des producteurs et des
acheteurs mais là où il y a un marché il
y a des traders c'est ce que nous avons
connu cet été avec un marché qui s'est
envolé avec un mégawattheure qui a
dépassé les 1000 euros ce n'est pas
sérieux et ce ne rend pas oser ni sur
les coûts de production ni même sur un
prix mais sur du trading et regarder
l'étendue des dégâts parce qu'il faut
donner des chiffres et des faits la
filiale Games qui est la filiale de
trading d'engie en 2021 écoutait bien
elle faisait 365 millions de bénéfices
combien en 2022 en pleine crise
énergétique deux milliards d'euros par
exemple mille énergie qui a bénéficié de
la reine à
10,5 euros le méga wattheure la revendue
sur le même marché au prix de 257 euros
sans rien produire en quelques jours 6
millions d'euros nets et le pire
scandale c'est que l'État a financé mine
d'énergie pour appliquer le bouclier
tarifaire à hauteur de 12 millions
d'euros 1000 énergie qui ne produit rien
et qui raquette les usagers c'est 18
millions de bénéfices net et il faut
donc arrêter ce massacre et se raquette
organisé oui il est possible de faire
autrement alors beaucoup de monde à
droite et partout sont maintenant comme
nous pour délayer le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité très bien mais comment
faire sans sortir de ce système vous
allez me dire aurait sur le coup
marginal sauf concernant le gaz mais on
va avoir un problème et c'est ce que
vous essayez de faire madame la ministre
c'est donc de plafonner et il y a trois
problèmes à ça cela un revient sub
donner une énergie fossile et évidemment
personne ici ne viendra dire que c'est
bon pour la planète le deuxième problème
c'est que les Allemands bloquent
évidemment puisque en restant dans ce
système qui lit le prix du gaz et
l'électricité ils ont un avantage
comparatif par rapport à nous le
troisième c'est que l'horizon 2023 et
2024 est très dégradé pour l'instant la
Chine est à l'arrêt mais lorsque ça va
repartir ils vont devoir acheter du gaz
à n'importe quel prix et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons du gaz américain
et katari mais en 2023 et 2024 il y aura
une compétition internationale et donc
les prix vont flamber et donc ceux qui à
l'intérieur du marché européen ont tout
intérêt à continuer à lier le prix du
gaz et l'électricité continueront à
bloquer alors oui nous le disons nous
pouvons prendre un autre chemin et nous
pouvons agir dès maintenant et avoir une
vision à long terme dès maintenant
obtenir une dérogation il faut arrêter
de nous dire que ce n'est pas possible
les Espagnols et les Portugais nous leur
montrer non pas qu'il fallait copier non
pas que nous soyons dans la même
situation ils sont en bout de chaîne
nous sommes au cœur du réseau mais ils
en ont montré que pour des États membres
il était possible d'avoir une dérogation
alors en boissons l'heure le pas
d'ailleurs l'Allemagne n'a pas demandé
de dérogation mais elle a mis 200
milliards sur la table poursuivant son
nez son économie
et nous demandons une dérogation pour
faire deux choses
réactiver les tarifs réglementés pour
tout le monde l'association
départementale de France des
départements de France le demande il
faut d'urgence
protéger les plus fragiles les usagers
les TPE et nos collectivités
territoriales et la blague qui vient à
dire que nous ayons obtenu des
énergéticiens un prix bloqué à 280 euros
est une aberration pourquoi parce que
les mêmes qui vous vendent dans 280
euros ont acheté pour 70% à 40 euros au
prix de la reine et donc écoutez bien
même sur ce les 30 derniers pour cent
même s'ils achètent sur le marché libre
à 800 euros ce qui serait une aberration
puisqu'il est entre 400 et 500 euros il
continueront à faire du profit donc il
faut un tarif réglementé bien sûr ça
coûte c'est 3 milliards et demi mais
l'an dernier nous avons donné combien en
bouclier tarifaires ont la sécurité 43
milliards d'euros donc réactivons ce qui
marche dernière chose il faut en finir
avec la reine je n'ai pas assez de temps
mais vous comprendrez que c'est un
système qui dépouille ira raquettes EDF
et les usagers et enfin nous devons
prendre la tête en Europe sortir de ce
mécanisme européen des traders et de
l'énergie libérale et nous le pouvons
parce que nous sommes la France et un
péripété et dire que nous voulons garder
les interconnexions que nous voulons un
système qui protège l'ensemble des
consommateurs à des consommatrices et
qui se base surtout sur un mix
électrique national évidemment nous nous
devons faire valoir notre intérêt celui
du nucléaire mais nous devons aider
celles et ceux qui dépendent très
fortement des énergies fossiles non pas
par la compétition mais par la
coopération pour sortir
l'ensemble du système européen des
énergies fossiles et répondre aux
besoins vitaux des peuples qui auront
toujours besoin d'énergie voilà je vous
remercie de votre attention
ça a été mon cadeau de bonne année mais
vous habituez pas dépasser de 30
secondes c'est pas c'est pas une
générosité partage et quand même bon
allez dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
François Bonnot pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 8 minutes
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
depuis près d'un an le marché d'énergie
connait des perturbations historiques
notamment en raison de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie le 24 février
2022 ce contexte international inédit au
21e siècle place le marché énergétique
en tension et a été le révélateur d'une
crise du marché électrique qui était
sous-jacente
en effet le système actuellement en
place
avec ce système là le prix du
mégawattheure a atteint des niveaux sans
précédent passant de 40 euros début 2021
à 400 euros le mégawattheure en
septembre 2022 de telle haute même si le
prix du megawater a tendance à baisser
récemment aux alentours de 137 euros ne
sont pas acceptables et supportables ni
pour nos entreprises ni pour l'ensemble
des particuliers
ces dernières s'expliquent notamment par
le fonctionnement actuel du marché
électrique européen qui nous place des
factos en économie de guerre
en effet le prix d'électricité étant
indecté indexé sur celui du gaz peu
importe le coût réel de la production le
prix final dépend du contexte
international que nous ne pouvons pas
contrôler
s'il convient de noter les interventions
de l'État pour contenir la hausse du
prix d'électricité à l'aide du bouclier
tarifaire de l'amortisseur d'électricité
ou encore des chèques énergie le
problème de fond n'est pas réglé
d'une part car de tel Z en
responsabilité coûte à l'état et ne
peuvent être durables d'autre part car
la crise de notre système électrique est
aussi structurelle la reine nous conduit
aujourd'hui avant notre production
électrique nucléaire à bas coût pour la
racheter ensuite plus cher sur le marché
européen
ce système en pleine crise est une
aberration qui profite au revendeur et
ce sont les consommateurs français qui
ont payé le prix fort
ce d'autant plus qu'il s'accompagne une
extension progressive des tarifs
réglementés de vente dont le coût se
répercute une fois de plus sur nos
concitoyens et sur nos entreprises
nationales
rappelons d'ailleurs que les énergies
renouvelables sont prioritaires lors de
l'injection sur le réseau
ce qui conduit à presque arrêté les
structures de production électrique
pilotables lorsqu'il y a du vent
notamment quelque part ça nous fait
payer deux fois la production comme nous
n'avons pas la maîtrise du stockage de
l'énergie à l'inverse lorsque les
énergies renouvelables sont à l'arrêt
nous n'avons plus suffisamment de
pilotables disponibles à fournir
notamment à cause de la reine et nous
payons jusqu'à 10 fois le prix ce qui
est insensé
à cela s'ajoute la mauvaise gestion
interne d'EDF avec un déficit financier
structurel est allé sur plusieurs années
qui est aujourd'hui particulièrement
préoccupant et contraint l'État à
reprendre la main
c'est aussi la gestion de l'entretien du
parc nucléaire
par l'entreprise qui nous place dans une
situation complexe
fin octobre puis la moitié du parc
nucléaire était hors d'usage en cause
des problèmes d'érosion sur des
réacteurs qui ont nécessité une
intervention rapide effet émerger des
critiques sur une potentielle négligence
vis-à-vis de l'entretien de ces mêmes
centrales rappelons qu'aux janvier de
cette année 12 des 56 réacteurs de ce
qui fut par le passé un fleuron
industriel français permettant une
production des carbonées pilotable et à
bas coût 12 de ces réacteurs étaient à
l'arrêt
l'électricité n'est pas un produit de
consommation comme un autre il ne doit
pas dépendre uniquement de l'offre et de
la demande mais tant pour sa production
que pour sa disponibilité auprès des
usagers il faut définir un cadre
souverain qui doit dépasser les seules
lois du marché
la proposition soumise à notre examen
aujourd'hui envisage de sortir le
système électrique des mécanismes
concurrentiels s'il est une certitude
c'est qu'effectivement nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter contenter du statu
quoctuel d'abord parce que les
particuliers sont aujourd'hui touchés de
plein fouet par cette crise et nous
pourrons en plus de l'inflation générale
supporter à long terme et sans aide des
factures électriques doublées triplés
quadruplé ou plus encore
un certain nombre d'entre eux et des
gens précarité énergétiques notre devoir
est des accompagné
d'autre part nos collectivités
territoriales sont asphyxiées
et ceux et avec elles ce sont tous les
territoires des services et une certaine
qualité de vie qui sont menacées
il s'agit d'une préoccupation majeure
dans chaque commune le maire doit
désormais choisir entre chauffer qu'on
aimement son école permettent à ses
admis très de faire du sport ou porter
des projets pour sa commune
certains m'opposeront qu'au nom de la
libre concurrence nous ne pouvons plus
aider nos collectivités financièrement
soit mais nous devons nous battre
collectivement pour qu'elles puissent
accéder à un tarif attractif qui ne
ferait pas l'objet de spéculation afin
de pouvoir continuer de pouvoir exercer
pour ceux qui l'auraient oublié des
missions de service public enfin car le
monde économique est menacé et réalise
ou défaitismes le spectre d'un mur de
faillite causé par des prix d'énergie se
dressent d'ores et déjà devant nous
nous boulanger baisse le rideau nous
restaurateur commence à manifester leur
crainte nos artisans arrivent à bout
leur capacités certaines grandes
entreprises préfèrent ne plus produire
et recourir au chômage partiel le marché
européen nous a fixé alors je le dis
clairement si nous ne pouvons pas aider
plus nos collectivités nos particuliers
nos TPE PME
c'est à la base du problème et avec
courage qu'il faut qu'il faut s'attaquer
les Français nous le demandent
pour agir concrètement désormais deux
voix s'offrent à nous une réforme du
marché d'électricité européen ou une
sortie du marché européen afin de
contrôler directement les prix de
l'électricité pour bien mesurer l'action
à mettre en oeuvre le premier point
crucial est de s'interroger sur la place
du nucléaire en France en effet
aujourd'hui nous sommes pénalisés si
nous n'utilisons pas assez d'énergie
renouvelables alors même que
l'électricité produite par la France et
4 fois plus décarbonée que celle
produite par l'Allemagne
des pistes européennes existent avec
notamment une refonte du marché
électricité qui devront s'accompagner
d'une réflexion approfondie sur la place
que doivent prendre les différentes
énergies renouvelables et nucléaires
notamment
une révision complète des règles
relatives au marché européen
d’électricité a été annoncé par la
Commission européenne le 18 octobre 2022
c'est une annonce à batterie mais qui
tarde à être concrétisée dans les faits
parmi les pistes évoquées ou actées lors
des derniers conseils européens on
propose d'une part de découpler les prix
du gaz et d'électricité afin de mettre
fin au système du méritordeur qui
conduit à une hausse artificielle du
prix d'électricité
d'autre part de plafonner le prix du gaz
et donc par extension de l'électricité
via la bourse TTF le marché gazier de
référence à l'échelle européenne mais le
contexte international ne nous y a pas
au-delà il y a également la piste pour
la France de sortir temporairement du
marché électrique européen c'est une
piste pertinente qu'il ne faut pas est
sûr
la dérogation temporaire aux règles du
marché de l'électricité à Corté aux deux
pays de la péninsule ibérique peut faire
des émules
il convient malgré tout de noter qu'il
s'agit d'une dérogation donc d'une
mesure d'exception qui a été accordée
utégare aux faibles nombre
d'interconnexions électriques du
Portugal et de l'Espagne
la majorité du groupe Union centriste
estime qu'une sortie dérogatoire est
temporaire du marché européen
électricité peut être opportunes rien ne
semble justifié qu'un pays comme la
France depuis son bénéficier également
les mêmes opportunités doit pouvoir être
offertes à l'ensemble des États membres
de l'Union
face à l'inaction gouvernementale nous
l'avions dit en séance publique lors de
l'examen de la proposition de loi
relatives à l'extension des tarifs
réglementés de vente de l'énergie le
sceptre décembre dernier une résolution
et l'outil parlementaire adéquate pour
allaiter alerter sur le caractère
européen de la problématique
structurelle que constitue la crise de
l'électricité
nous avions également dit que nous
soutiendrons un texte sans idéologie ni
dogmatisme qui mettra en lumière les
dysfonctionnements du marché européen
électricité nous saluons la volonté aux
objectifs initiaux des auteurs mais nous
souscrivons aucunement à l'ensemble des
propos tenus par les auteurs de cette
proposition n'accusant pas les
libératisme de tous les mots un monopole
et une économie administrée n'ont jamais
permis de préserver durablement le
pouvoir d'achat nous prenons aucunement
une fin d'intégration européenne nous
sommes en faveur d'un assouplissement
des règles et d'une refonte complète de
celle-ci tout cela est primordial puis
en faveur d'une limitation du temps
merci infiniment vous avez déjà dépassé
depuis 30 secondes bonne année c'est pas
Noël tous les jours quand même allez oui
je vois la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Henri Cabanel pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues la crise
actuelle de l'énergie c'est les études
du GIEC n'avaient pas réussi à
convaincre certains jusque là sonne le
glas de l'illusion de son abondance
notre impréparation généralisée conduit
à ce que les États soient dans
l'obligation de répondre en urgence des
situations de pénurie la prospective
devient indispensable en matière de
stratégie énergétique qui doit pouvoir
être souple dans les incertitudes sont
nombreuses pour pouvoir assurer notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement préserver
nos concitoyens maintenir la vie
économique du pays et les emplois si
l'électricité constitue un bien de
première nécessité comme la reconnu le
Conseil d'État ce statut malheureusement
pas été reconnu pour le gaz justifiant
ainsi en droit la suppression
progressive des tarifs réglementés de
vente
les différences intervenants de la Table
Ronde organisées au Sénat décembre
dernier par la commission des affaires
économiques que l'on souligné le marché
européen a été conçu pour gérer
l'abondance d'énergie depuis sa création
la situation approfondément évolué du
fait d'une combinaison de crise
sanitaire et géopolitique et climatique
si les premières n'étaient pas
prévisibles la fin des énergies fossiles
et le réchauffement climatique l'été bel
et bien ainsi le marché tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui ne peut être
adapté à ses défis des économistes le
reconnaissent ce marché n'incite pas
l'investissement sur le long terme il ne
répond plus aux promesses avancées au
moment de sa création meilleur coup pour
les usagers sécurité d'approvisionnement
indépendance énergétique comme la
constaté la Cour des comptes dans un
rapport publié en juillet 2022 les
terres V sont de plus en plus exposés à
variations des prix de marché au risque
de s'éloigner plus nettement des coûts
de production d'EDF
l'intégration du coût
d'approvisionnement des fournisseurs
alternatifs sur les marchés de gros dans
le calcul de ces tarifs pour assurer
leur contextabilité provoque leur
réafléchissement
mettons donc fin au système de la reine
instauré par la loi norme du 7 décembre
2017 qui engendre une concurrence
subventionnée pénalise EDF et donc les
investissements dans la production
d'énergie décarbonée au profit de
fournisseurs alternatifs qui n'ont que
très peu produit et qui sont de simples
traders cependant l'échec actuel du
marché n'explique pas tout nous avons
accumulé un retard considérable sur tous
les fronts renouvelables nucléaire
efficacité énergétique économie
d'énergie ou encore résilience des
réseaux
que l'on préserve des mécanismes
concurrentiels ou non je ne crois pas
pour ma part que les prix de l'énergie
puissent artificiellement baisser ils
doivent en effet couvrir les coups de
production qui eux augmenteront dans les
années à venir au regard du mur
d'investissement qui nous attend il n'y
a pas de magie aussi la sortie de la
France du marché européenne de l'énergie
plus qu'une solution s'avérerait
fortement déstabilisatrice les échanges
transfentraliés doivent être maintenus
sinon développés en attendant
assurons-nous que ces prix n'excèdent
pas le coup de production auquel il
serait ajouté une marge raisonnable
c'est le sens de l'adoption de en loi de
finances de la taxe sur un rente infram
marginal qui devrait se rapporter entre
7 et 11 milliards d'euros en 2023
peut-on réellement conjurer la
volatilité des prix et la spéculation
oui je le pense la piste des contrats de
long terme à d'autres énergies que les
renouvelables ça va avancer de donner de
la visibilité pour tous les acteurs de
calmer le jeu et de leur permettre
d'investir dans de nouvelles capacités
de production avec un peu plus de
sérénité
certes l'Union européenne n'a pour
l'instant proposé que des solutions
temporaires il regrettable que chaque
État membre continue de négocier des
dérogations dans son coin créant une
concurrence fossée il regrettable qu'on
paye encore l’influence de l'Allemagne
sur l’architecture du marché et les
décisions prises au départ de ses
voisins en premier lieu de la France la
sortie du nucléaire et le soutien fort
au gaz pour compenser l'intermittence de
leur énergie renouvelable le mériteur et
la détermination du prix de
l'électricité par le coût de la dernière
centrale appelée le plus souvent le gaz
leur bénéficie pleinement la réforme
doit être étudiée discutée afin de
dessiner un mécanisme à la fois juste et
solidaire au niveau européen et surtout
le Parlement devait être informé de
manière permanente de l'état de ses
négociations et des solutions envisagées
le gouvernement plaide au niveau plein
de pardon au niveau européen pour une
des
corrélations pardon du prix de
l'électricité de celui du gaz pour un
plafonnement du prix de l'énergie sur le
marché de gros qui vient d'être tractée
mais la réalité surtout que la demande
est supérieure à l'offre ce problème de
volume ne constitue pas une situation
provisoire aussi la solution à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie n'est pas
aussi simple que de sortir le système
électrique des mécanismes concurrentiels
ni techniquement ni économiquement ni
juridiquement je vous remercie
il y a même de récupérer les 30 secondes
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Stéphane piennois
pour le groupe les républicains pour 8
minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
délestage blackout sobriété et même col
roulé depuis plusieurs mois les Français
sont bercé pour ne pas dire inondés d'un
verbe intime anxiogène qui fait craindre
dans l'immédiat un passage difficile de
l'hiver et des factures énergétiques qui
explosent et dans un second temps qui
interroge sur les raisons profondes
d'une telle situation
reconnaissons que personne ne prêtait
vraiment attention aux comparatifs de
coûts de l'électricité historiquement
très favorable à notre pays et qui
montrait régulièrement un rapport de 1 à
3 par exemple avec nos voisins allemands
et encore moins nombreux étaient ceux
qui s'intéressaient de près à la raison
de se différencier important pour la
commercialisation des électrons si
essentiels à notre vie de tous les jours
il a fallu finalement la violence d'une
crise énergétique sans précédent ou
presque pour comprendre le mécanisme
infernal dans lequel la France s'est
fourvoyée
chacun a bien compris maintenant que
l'électricité peut être produite de
différents moyens nucléaires hydraulique
éolien photovoltaïques biomasse gaz
pétrole et même charbon de l'option
choisie dépendent le coût de production
et son impact environnemental chaque
pays faisant finalement son choix en
fonction de potentiel propre et aussi de
donner géopolitiques parfois ancienne
c'est particulièrement vrai sur notre
continent
ainsi l'Allemagne a hérité d'un
approvisionnement en gaz russe
relativement bon marché mais très
émetteur de CO2 tout en s'appuyant sur
des centrales à charbon au bilan
écologique inversement proportionnel au
rendement économique
de son côté la France s'est orientée dès
les années 50 vers le nucléaire très bon
marché et très faiblement carboné
contribuant progressivement à assurer sa
souveraineté dans le domaine en quelque
sorte chacun sa stratégie pour composer
son mix électrique sans solliciter une
quelconque autorisation auprès de
l'Union européenne tout en s'associant
bien évidemment pour construire un
réseau européen de l'électricité une
sorte de solidarité communautaire pour
assurer une disponibilité et une
circulation d'un bout à l'autre du
continent de ces fameux électrons
voilà pour planter le décor de la
proposition de résolution qui nous ont
proposé par le groupe CRCE aujourd'hui
dont je partage plusieurs éléments mais
qui ratent sa cible à mon avis pour deux
raisons essentielles premièrement une
confusion dans l'analyse deuxièmement un
biais idéologique très fort
premièrement il n'est pas judicieux de
remettre en cause le mécano énergétique
que j'ai décrit ce marché unique de
l'énergie qui est en pleine accord avec
les principes fondamentaux de la
construction européenne en réalité on
peut même admettre que cela constitue un
certain équilibre dans ce réseau ainsi
interconnecté du fait de logique
différente dans la production faisant
appel à des sources d'approvisionnement
diversifiées et donc équilibré
mais c'est d'ailleurs que le bât blesse
marcher unique ne signifie pas
tarification unique à quel moment
avons-nous accepté de fixer de coûts de
production sur ce nettement moins
avantageux de pays certes partenaires
mais qui doivent pouvoir assumer seul
leur propre stratégie à quel moment
avons-nous accepter de lier les destins
électriques de pays aux orientations
divergentes en se basant sur les moins
vertueux
il y a s'il y a bien une chose que l'on
n'attend pas de la construction
européenne c'est qu'elles mettent à mal
des stratégies industrielles nationales
ou qu'elles sacrifie un avantage
concurrentiel c'est pourtant exactement
ce qui a été scellé certes de manière
discrète mais tout aussi sournoise avec
la tarification européenne de l'énergie
en indexant le coût de l'électricité sur
celui du gaz au motif qu'il s'agirait de
la dernière énergie capable de produire
notre électricité en cas de pénurie on
Bafou complètement notre souveraineté ça
va manque construite par le président
Pompidou dans les années 70 c'est un peu
comme si le prix des agrumes était
indexé sur le coup de production dans
les Pays-Bas au sol motif qu'il
s'agirait d'une main d'oeuvre plus
facilement mobilisable en dernier
recours sans considération particulière
sur la météo de ces pays absurde
ce mécanisme de calcul intègre donc le
coût sur le marché de gros soumis à de
fortes fluctuations déjà de pilotone
2021 et d'une manière encore plus aiguë
depuis le conflit en Ukraine dont l'une
des conséquences nous le savons bien et
l'envoler du prix du gaz lié à l'arrêt
de l'approvisionnement russe de surcroît
ce tarif calculé n'est absolument pas
capté d'où des cours instantanés
totalement délirants jusqu'à 2000 euros
le mégawattheure cette situation n'est
d'ailleurs pas sans rappeler les prêts
dit structurer les prêts toxiques à
l'époque qui ont tant mis en difficulté
les collectivités locales qui ont fait
confiance à une formule basée sur la
parité euro-dollar qui ne devait en
aucun cas pouvoir s'inverser jusqu'à la
crise des subprimes
bien sûr soyez tranquille le président
Macron a bien identifié le problème et
promis de convaincre ses collègues
européens de revenir sur ce mécanisme à
l'instar de l'Espagne et du Portugal qui
ont atteint cet objectif avec moins d'en
face mais bien plus d'efficacité
en effet pour quels résultats à ce jour
l'annonce du dernier Conseil européen
est assez impressionnant je cite le
mécanisme de correction du marché sera
automatiquement activée si l'événement
de correction du marché suivant ce
produit premièrement le prix TTF à un
mois dépasse 180 euros le mégawattheure
pendant 3 jours ouvrables deuxièmement
le prix TTF à un mois est supérieur de
35 euros au prix de référence GNL sur
les marchés mondiaux pendant les trois
premiers jours les trois même jour
ouvrables une vraie prouesse
technocratique il faut vraiment en finir
avec cette tarification absurde qui
piétine toute politique nationale aussi
judicieuse soit elle
imaginez un peu mes chers collègues si
jamais nous dirigeants avaient continué
sur la voie pompidolienne nous serions
non pas les rois du pétrole mais les
empereurs de l'électricité et notre
modèle énergétique s'imposerait
vraisemblablement à l'ensemble du
continent européen
j'en viens ce que je sais que vous
attendez au billet d'ordre idéologique
de nos collègues du groupe CRCE
s'agissant de leur analyse sur le
caractère concurrentiel de ce marché de
l'énergie
sans doute nostalgique d'une économie
totalement anémie qui n'a pourtant pas à
travers l'histoire mondiale rencontrer
le succès escompté vous accablez le
caractère libéral du marché européen
mais en vérité il s'agit seulement du
mécanisme de la reine qui est en cause à
savoir livrer à des fournisseurs une
partie de la production de l'opérateur
historique au prix concurrentiel de
l'énergie d'origine nucléaire donc
quasiment sans aucune contrepartie et
sans aucun algorithme de réajustement en
fonction de la conjoncture c'est ça qui
est en cause la véritable ouverture à la
concurrence consisterait à permettre à
des producteurs de proposer leurs
propres tarif de fournitures dans une
logique d'optimisation des coûts
complets dont les bénéficiaires seraient
en définitive vraiment les consommateurs
nous sommes très loin de ce schéma qui
d'ailleurs ne vous conviendrait sans
doute pas davantage
donc si nous partageons plusieurs
constats sur les conséquences de la
tarification européenne pour nos
concitoyens avec mes collègues du groupe
LR nous ne voterons pas cette PPR pour
les raisons que je viens d'évoquer
précédemment néanmoins nous sommes
conscients du travail qu'il reste à
engager pour changer ce mécanisme
absurde et je conclurai pour ne pas vous
faire plaisir mais pour aller dans votre
sens par cette devise du camarade Lénine
que vous partagerez certainement là où
il y a une volonté il y a un chemin je
vous remercie
oui enfin là où il est une volonté il y
a un chemin il y a au moins 10 paires de
la formule parce que allez on va pas se
battre là-dessus merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Jean-Louis lagourde pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la crise énergétique
que nous traversons nous fragilise
considérablement nos ménages sont
fortement impactés nos entreprises et
tout le tissu entrepreneurial sont
menacés
leur compétitivité compétitivité de
notre pays et plus largement celle de
l'Union européenne seront fortement
affectés il est impératif que l'Union
sorte de sa dépendance aux énergies
fossiles en provenance particulièrement
de la Russie à ce titre le plan ripower
UE est un outil intéressant il repose
sur un triptyque simple faire en sorte
d'effectuer des économies d'énergie
diversifier nos sources
approvisionnement en énergie et surtout
produire notre énergie de manière propre
que ce soit sur la loi sur
l'accélération du déploiement des unr
dont nous avons discuté l'an dernier et
qu'il étape de la CNP ou celle de
l'accélération du nucléaire que nous
allons examiner en sciences publiques la
semaine prochaine nous devons aller vite
et être efficace ces textes ne sont que
le début de notre
groupe déjà tourné vers les prochaines
échéances un projet de loi énergétique
climat et la PPE l'Union européenne est
incontournable comme s'il s'agit
d'énergie n'oublions pas que c'est une
compétence partagée entre l'UE et les
États membres
se met en place au fur et à mesure
depuis 2019 traduisant une volonté de
transition écologique la transition
énergétique en fait partie des réponses
arrivent également concernant la crise
actuelle malgré les difficultés visibles
lors des conseils européens tout au long
de l'année 2022 le 22 décembre dernier
un règlement d'idiots établissant un
cadre en vue d'accélérer le déplacement
des déploiements des énergies
renouvelables a été publiée au Journal
officiel de l'UE le texte est
d'application directe pour les 18
prochains mois
le travail des États membres de concert
avec l'Union européenne un véritable
valeur ajoutée le marché intérieur
européen de l'énergie est une force mais
il n'est pas abouti la réforme
structurelle annoncée est plus que
nécessaire d'abord parce que si les
graines sont fortes hiver
elles le sont toutes tendres les hivers
prochains ensuite parce que le système
doit être mieux adapté c'est pourquoi
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec le
point 12 de cette PPA qui évoque l'échec
de l'ouverture à la concurrence du
marché de l'énergie ce marché a des
avantages importants pour la France qui
vont au-delà de l'interconnexion qui
permet de ne pas manquer d'énergie aussi
de revendre l'énergie que nous
produisons cette année particulière pour
nos installations nucléaires mais
n'oublions pas à l'heure où on travaille
à la relance
que nous revendons aussi beaucoup sur le
marché européen de l'énergie je salue
l'implication du gouvernement sur le
principe de découplage du prix du gaz et
du prix d'électricité notre groupe
soutient se découplage et l'appel de CV
depuis plusieurs mois de manière
générale nous soutenons la réforme du
marché européen énergie mais ce que
notre groupe ne souhaite absolument pas
c'est une sortie de fée de ce marché les
difficultés seraient bien plus grandes
sur le point relatif au barrage
hydraulique il est crucial et notre
groupe à une position claire nous avons
encore lors des lignes accueillage de
décembre exprimé d'autres souhaits de
voir ce dossier évoluer et des
situations comme la création de STEP se
débloquait hier matin en audition devant
la commission des affaires économiques
Madame le Ministre
a été transparent sur la volonté de
stratégie avec le nouveau patron de DF
pour aborder les négociations à venir
avec la Commission européenne
Diderot électricité fait partie de notre
avenir et de notre souveraineté elle
dégage notre indépendance énergétique
cependant pour tout ce que j'ai évoqué
avant et les dirigeants de points de vue
sur les solutions face au marché
européennes l'énergie le groupe les
indépendants ne peuvent voter en faveur
de cette PPA je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologiste pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le vidéaste Rika a tenté
d'expliquer le marché commun européen de
l'électricité auxquels soyons francs pas
grand monde ne comprend pas grand chose
pas même le ministre de l'économie qui
est aussi entre approximation et contre
vérité là où une vidéo de vulgarisation
dure généralement quelques dizaines de
minutes il a fallu à notre vidéaste
quatre vidéos et plus de 3h30
d'explications pour venir à bout du
marché de l'électricité
je vais tenter dans les 5 minutes qui me
sont impartis d'exprimer notre position
sur ce débat central et je remercie au
passage nos collègues communistes de le
porter alors du jour de notre assemblée
à l'époque il était impossible de croire
que ce mécanisme il était plutôt
possible encore de croire que ce
mécanisme de libération permettrait
d'accélérer le déploiement des énergies
ne renouvelables ENR totalement délaissé
par EDF enfermé dans sa stratégie tout
nucléaire dont les limites sautent
chaque jour un peu plus aux yeux 20 ans
plus tard forcer de constater que le
compte n'y est pas le marché européen
était censé offrir le meilleur prix au
consommateurs au lieu de cela comme le
prix est commun et que les Europe les
opérateurs refusent de faire tourner
leur centrales à perte il instaure de
fait un prix unique basé sur le coup de
production de la dernière centrale
mobilisée le plus cher du continent le
marché était censé favoriser la
multiplication des producteurs
fournisseurs d'énergie particulièrement
renouvelable il a essentiellement créé
des fournisseurs qui ne produisent rien
ce gaffe car c'est bien le mot sur le
dos du contribuable grâce au tarif
réglementé et à la reine pour le
développement de la production de NR
notamment les règles de marché étant
structurellement inadaptées l'État a eu
recours à des contrats de long terme
après garantir avec les opérateurs d'une
manière générale ouvrir à la concurrence
les monopoles naturels et multiplier les
acteurs privés en utilisant la même
infrastructure publique unie est une
curiosité dont on a vu toutes les
limites avec le rail et il faudra hélas
encore quelques années à certains pour
s'en apercevoir pour l'électricité il
faut à chaque instant produire dans des
quantités suffisantes mais sans surplus
multiplier les acteurs privés avant tout
soucieux de leur marge sur un réseau
interconnecté reliant une trentaine de
pays relèvent tout simplement de
l'inconscience résultat des courses une
spéculation débridée des tarifs
totalement déconnectés des coûts de
production c'est encore une fois l'état
à coup de bouclier tarifaire qui vient
amortir certains conséquence l'échec est
complet à part quelques libéraux dogmat
le confinement fanatisme tout le monde
le concède malgré quelques réticences
les États membres ont enfin décidé de
restructurer le marché unique de
l'électricité mais à ce stade ni la
proposition de la Commission de
plafonner à 200 euros par mégawattheure
les prix d'achat au producteurs
disposant des centrales les moins chers
ni la proposition française de
développer des contrats long terme
public ou privés ne semble en mesure de
protéger les consommateurs de la
volatilité des prix ou de sécuriser les
investissements nécessaires à la
transition énergétique ces propositions
ne sont pas à la hauteur de la tente des
artisans boulanger en tête qui voit leur
facture mais publiées par trois quatre
ou cinq ni des 12 millions de nos
compatriotes en situation de précarité
énergétique ni de nos industriels qui
menacent de délocaliser ni de nos
collectivités qui sont obligés
d'augmenter les impôts locaux elles ne
sont pas plus à la hauteur de l'urgence
de la transition énergétique qui exige
de la visibilité à moyen et long terme
pour tous les acteurs
seule la puissance publique est en
mesure de réguler les prix payés par les
consommateurs en harmonisant les coûts
et variables d'un type de production à
l'autre et de planifier les
investissements nécessaires à la
transition l'énergie n'est pas une
marchandise comme les autres c'est un
bien commun dont la fourniture a pris
réguler doit être garantie c'est le sens
de la proposition des écologistes lors
de l'élection présidentielle de remettre
à plat et directives européennes je
précise au passage que contrairement à
ce que veut bien raconter le ministre
suspendre ou sortir du marché commun de
l'électricité ce n'est certainement pas
mettre un terme à la solidarité ou au
commerce d'électricité entre pays
européens qui a existé avant et kick
extra et qui existera après le marché
unique c'est le sens également de notre
proposition de renationaliser EDF pour
en faire un bras armé de la transition
énergétique de notre volonté de
conserver les barrages hydroélectriques
dans le giron public tout comme de
propositions de loi visant à créer un
service public des énergies
renouvelables le groupe écologiste
partage les principaux objectifs de
cette résolution en rappelant son
attachement viscéral au respect de la
règle commune européenne il demande au
gouvernement de plaider avec force à
Bruxelles pour une remise à plat total
des mécanismes concurrentiels et dans
ces conditions il apporte son soutien
plein entier à cette proposition de
résolution merci merci monsieur le
Président
la parole est maintenant monsieur André
gatelin pour le groupe RDPI pour 6
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la discussion que
nous avons là sur cette proposition de
résolution est très importante sur le
fond et je tiens particulièrement à
remercier son auteur notre collègue
Fabien gay sans connaisseur et Vichy sur
ses sujets et tout cela un sujet très
sensible et je dois dire que je partage
certains des constats qu'il dresse
concernant les imperfections de
l'organisation du marché actuel de
l'électricité sur les abus constatés et
la nécessité de réformer au-delà
d'ailleurs des imperfections liées à la
manière dont nous avons procédé à la
libéralisation en France pour nous
conformer aux directives européennes
ouvrant les secteurs de la production et
de la fourniture d'électricité à la
concurrence il ne faut cependant pas
omettre de rappeler que si les prix de
l'énergie ont atteint des sommets des
niveaux records en 2022 c'est
essentiellement en raison de l'agression
de l'ukra par la Russie et l'utilisation
par cette dernière de
l'approvisionnement en gaz comme une
arme de guerre la flambée des prix du
gaz qui en a découlé ses répercutés sur
le prix de l'électricité produite dans
les centrales à gaz et par truchement
sur les prix de l'électricité la
corrélation qui a été établie entre le
prix du gaz et le prix de l'électricité
à travers le principe de la précédente
économique qu'on appelle ici Merry Tower
calculer sur le coût marginal de la
dernière source de production mobilisée
le gaz en l'occurrence n'est pas
étrangère à cette situation actuelle de
flamber des prix et il faut dire le
gouvernement français était un des
premiers à militer pour une réforme de
ce mécanisme afin de procéder à une
décorrélation du prix du gaz de celui de
l'électricité sur le marché européen
s'il existe des raisons objectives de
critiquer aujourd'hui ce mécanisme de
fixation du prix de l'électricité au
niveau européen c'est précisément je
crois parce que la question de la
sécurité des approvisionnements
énergétiques atroce souvent ces
dernières années étaient mises sous le
tapis nous avons ainsi privilégié un
coup de l'énergie et surtout un coût de
l'électricité le plus bas possible à
court terme au détriment d'une vision à
plus long terme visant à garantir une
plus grande indépendance énergétique de
notre continent nous avons facilité la
consommation au détriment des
investissements dans la production de
l'énergie électrique car celle-ci
engendrait évidemment un coût final plus
élevé alors certains sont tentés comme
le fait cette proposition d'en faire
porter la responsabilité à l'Europe et à
la libéralisation du marché de
l'électricité on oublie de dire que nous
avons nous en avons aussi beaucoup
bénéficier au niveau national jusqu'à la
guerre en Ukraine et que le mécanisme de
la présence économique a aussi largement
contribué au développement des énergies
renouvelables on oublie également de
dire que nombre de dysfonctionnements
constaté aujourd'hui proviennent aussi
de la manière dont nous avons géré la
libéralisation du secteur
essentiellement au profit des
distributeurs d'électricité plutôt qu'au
profit des producteurs et la loi norme
adoptée par le Parlement français ici
même en 2010 est loin d'avoir rempli ses
objectifs en matière de diversification
de l'offre de production et à même
généré certains effets spéculatifs
d'ailleurs justement dénoncé par notre
collègue Fabien gay par ailleurs je veux
rappeler ici que nous étions très peu
nombreux voire pratiquement pas nombreux
du tout dans cette hémicycle il y a sept
ans soit deux ans après
l'invasion de la Crimée à nous opposer à
la production du gazotuc 9 stream 2 qui
accroissait à l'époque significativement
nos dépendances énergétique à la Russie
en revanche et au même moment elle a
même époque nous nous sommes ici opposés
au Sénat en commission des affaires
européennes et très fermement il y a une
seule voix contre la mienne à une
proposition de décision du Parlement
européen et du Conseil qui justement au
nom de la sécurité d'approvisionnement
de l'UE en gaz naturel voulait obliger
les États membres à soumettre ex hanté à
la Commission pour évaluation et suivie
tout leur projet d'accord
intergouvernementaux avec des États non
membres de l'Union européenne en matière
d'achat de gaz alors oui il faut
travailler à une réforme rapide du
marché européen de l'électricité et dans
quelques jours l'Union ouvrira une
consultation publique à ce sujet
consultation à laquelle je vous invite
de participer parce que nous sommes trop
peu nombreux généralement il y a 20 fois
plus de participants allemands que le
participant français
cette consultation préalable à l'élobe
Bresson d'une nouvelle législation qui
devrait voir le jour au printemps la
Ministre chargée des affaires
européennes que nous avons positionné ce
matin en commission des affaires
européennes nous la confirmé cette
réforme devra viser à faire baisser les
prix actuels et à les rendre moins
volatile sans sacrifier la transition
écologique et en faisant en sorte
notamment que le principe de préférence
économique prennent désormais en compte
les coûts réels de la production
d'électricité alors mieux réguler le
marché de l'électricité oui mais non pas
sortir du système électrique et le
système électrique des mécanismes
concurrentiels et du système européen
les conséquences directes et indirectes
notre exit énergétique serait
extrêmement grave pour notre pays il
faut rappeler ici que si la France n'a
pas connu le mois dernier de délestage
ce n'est pas seulement parce que notre
consommation électrique a diminué c'est
surtout parce que nous avons pu importer
de l'électricité grâce à
l'interconnexion des réseaux et
l'existence d'un marché de gros
garantissant des prix corrects le temps
me manque ici mais je vous invite mes
chers collègues à étudier de près la
situation énergétique actuelle du
Royaume-Uni pays qui reste interconnecté
mais qui est sorti du marché européen et
qui effectivement procède à des achats
de gré à gré à des prix particulièrement
élevés suivez la situation des coûts
énergétiques au Royaume-Uni et ça sera
peut-être une raison de vous convaincre
de la fausse bonne solution qui nous ont
proposé vous l'avez compris le groupe
RDPI votre a contre cette résolution je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Franck
Montauger pour le groupe socialiste pour
5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues je remercie nos
collègues du groupe CRCE d'avoir mis au
débat cette proposition de résolution
qui invite le gouvernement à sortir le
système électrique des mécanismes
concurrentiels indéniablement et tous
nos compatriotes le vivent dans la
difficulté du quotidien ou de leurs
entreprises le marché européen de
l'électricité n'a pas répondu aux
objectifs finissants qui lui étaient
assignés le principe de la libre
concurrence non fossé n'a pas permis de
diminuer le prix de l'électricité il
alimente aujourd'hui l'inflation et n'a
rien permis de diminuer la précarité
énergétique en France il a même conduit
à l’affaiblissement du plus important
énergéticienne d'Europe et un des tous
premiers au monde EDF à des saints ou
par déficience de pilotage stratégiques
de l'État actionnaire majoritaire EDF a
été sacrifié sur l'hôtel de la
concurrence
ce qui marchait jusque là et participer
grandement de notre souveraineté
industrielle nationale a été déconstruit
affaibli et je le rappelle le critère
d'évaluation de la réussite du
développement du marché n'était pas le
prix ni la qualité du service mais le
nombre et la proportion d'électricité
vendue par des fournisseurs des
fournisseurs alternatifs à EDF
fournisseur alternatif qui n'ont jamais
respecté l'obligation initiale qui leur
était faite de produire par leur propre
moyen de l'électricité du négoce du
commerce j'achète et je revends et une
proportion importante de ce que je
revends à un prix administré via le
mécanisme de la reine dont on sait la
destruction de valeur qu'il a été pour
l'entreprise nationale EDF
tout cela pour en arriver à quoi bien
avant l'agression russe de l'Ukraine une
envolée d'abord progressive des prix
alimentée par une crise de l'offre et
des pratiques de spéculation qui ont
largement enrichi les traders des
marchés de l'énergie si certains
consommateurs se sont appauvris et ont
plongé dans la difficulté d'autres
annoncer leur richesse rien n'est des
surplus spéculatifs de valeur générée
par le marché ne s'est perdu pas contre
par contre nos concitoyens nos artisans
nos TPE ti jusqu'à nos collectivités
locales et nos grandes entreprises
industrielles dont les électro-intensifs
en ont payé et en perron encore
longtemps les conséquences financières
au risque pour beaucoup d’une plus
grande précarité ou de la perte de leur
outil de travail parce que c'est aussi
de ça qu'il s'agit nous en sommes là
pris entre d'un côté les USA qui mettent
en œuvre leur très patriotiques actes
de réduction de l'inflation et les
chinois dont la politique de l'offre est
financée par l'État et tout ça en déni
total des règles de l'OMC ou de ce qu'il
en reste dans ce contexte extrêmement
préoccupable qu'attendons-nous du
gouvernement non pour répondre aux
difficultés de l'instant il apporte
quelques solutions
conjoncturelles mais pour répondre aux
problèmes structurels du marché de
l'électricité c'est la question que pose
cette PPR dont nous partageons
totalement les constats et la
problématique l'électricité n'est pas un
bien marchand comme un autre elle est
d'abord puis que tout autre produit au
cœur de la civilisation elle le sera
plus encore le temps passant eu égard
aux transitions que doit opérer notre
société pour être au rendez-vous
climatique de la neutralité carbone en
2050 on la retrouve dans l'alimentation
dans les transports dans l'habitat
absolument partout comme l’ont été
depuis plus de deux siècles les énergies
fossiles elles ne se stocke pas à grande
échelle et elle nécessite un ajustement
parfait et permanent entre la production
et la consommation en définitive
l'électricité est un bien commun il doit
être appréhendé comme tel d'abord ce qui
est aujourd'hui hors du marché doit le
rester c'est le cas des concessions
hydroélectriques en premier lieu la
régulation encore existante doit être
préservée c'est le cas des TRD qui
doivent être élargies au-delà du seuil
de 36 cavéa et comme nous le demande
tous les entrepreneurs j'insiste sur le
tout tous les contrats
d'approvisionnement doivent répondre à
deux objectifs à conjuguer d'une part
visibilité à moyen terme moyen long
terme et d'autre part stabilité des prix
dans le temps les prix doivent être
indépendants du marché des énergies
fossiles la proposition de résolution
propose d'extraire le marché de
l'électricité de la concurrence nous
pensons que si cette option doit être
privilégiée des régulations spécifiques
doivent aussi être env chaque fois que
nous interrogeons le gouvernement sur
ses propositions de réforme
structurelles du marché qu'il porte au
sein des instances européennes aucun
début de réponse ou d'orientation un
temps soit peu concret ne nous est
apporté madame la ministre prenez vos
responsabilités pour défendre l'intérêt
général des Français à Bruxelles passer
en fin des déclarations d'intention à la
négociation et dites-nous aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît les options de réforme
structurelles que vous entendez porter
dans l'intérêt de la France comme de
l'Union européenne je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant au président
Pierre Laurent pour le groupe CRCE pour
5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues cela fait plus de 15
mois que la folle envolée des prix de
l'énergie déstabilise le pouvoir d'achat
des Européens des Français à Sicile et
budgets de nos communes et menace la vie
économique de nos entreprises et depuis
15 mois économiste expert ministre a
commencé par Bruno Le Maire ici même à
plusieurs reprises s'accordent sur un
point il y a un urgent problème avec
l'organisation actuelle du marché
européen et de la fixation des prix de
l'électricité or depuis 15 mois rien ne
se passe sur ce point avec cette
proposition de résolution nous vous
proposons d'envoyer un signal fort pour
dire ça suffit la France ne veut plus du
système actuel de fixation des prix en
vérité le problème est structurel la
hausse a été forte et continue bien
avant la guerre en Ukraine la
déstabilisation récente n'a fait que
révéler des failles structurelles liées
au mécanisme de libéralisation et de
privatisation
qui ont enfermé les marchés gaziers
électriques dans des logiques
concurrentielles courtes thermistes le
Market design inventé par strat
successives par les instances
européennes à imposer une concurrence
artificielle contraire à la rationalité
économique du secteur de la production
et de la distribution énergétique et
pour plusieurs raisons le soi-disant
marcher européen de l'électricité
néanmia homogène puisque les mixes de
production demeurent de la compétence
des États membres pour ce qui nous
concerne nous visons un mix nucléaire
ENR pour décarboner l'électricité en
conséquence les coûts de production les
coûts de transition diffèrent d'un état
à l'autre d'autre part il n'y a pas de
mécanisme unique de fixation des prix
des tarifs liés à ces coûts le secteur
européen de l'électricité donc un
florilège de réglementation de contrats
toujours plus complexe pour prix pour
protéger le trading enfin s'il n'est
évidemment pas question comme ça a été
dit par mon collègue Fabien gay de
mettre fin aux interconnexions
et que nous pouvons les gérer sur la
base de règles qui se définissent
facilement nous constatons tous qu'une
part mineure de l'énergie produite
échangée sur le marché de gros et il est
souhaitable que cela constitue pour
continuer pour sécuriser notre
approvisionnement et pourtant c'est ce
marché minoritaires qui est responsable
de l'emballement spéculatif et
inflationniste qui met aujourd'hui les
particuliers les entreprises en danger
l'envolée récente des prix de gros de
l'électricité en Europe ne reflètent
donc pas la réalité des échanges mais
seulement ceux qui se réalisent sur les
bourses seuls ce marché fixe le prix
alors qu'en France moins d'un tiers des
échanges d'électricité se font sur le
marché de court terme les autres
résultats de contrats résultant de
contrats de long terme avec l'État pour
les EnR ou via la reine pour le
nucléaire historique dans ces conditions
la règle de la dernière centrale appelée
loin de permettre l'optimisation du
système électrique est devenu une source
de sa déstabilisation c'est pourquoi la
sortie de mécanismes concurrentiels qui
sont sans rapport avec les réalités
industrielles de production est urgente
il est impératif non seulement de
décorréler le prix de l'électricité de
celui du gaz mais d'organiser la sortie
de ces mécanismes pour revenir à une
politique tarifaire décider sur la base
des coûts de production et non pas sur
les intérêts d'acteurs parasites
seulement intéressés à tirer le meilleur
profit de ces mécanismes contraires à
l'intérêt général cette sortie est
d'autant plus indispensable qu'une
stabilité retrouvée des prix plus
conformes à nos coûts de production et
aux besoins d'investissement est
indispensable dans la durée pour
garantir la souveraineté industrielle
nécessaire à la sécurité de notre
approvisionnement comme pour planifier
les investissements massifs nécessaires
à la décarbonation sans vision de long
terme nous allons dans le mur or ce
marché et organiser sur le court terme
spéculatif nous ne pouvons plus accepter
noter que ce bien universel essentiel
soit confixée confisqué par ces logiques
de profit aveugles la volatilité des
prix obéir les investissements dans le
système électrique ainsi que dans sa
transformation écologique elle dilapide
les fonds publics dans des boucliers
tarifaires qui bougent autant de trous
qu'ils ont créé en continuant à financer
des acteurs spéculatifs alors que la
garantie d'un prisme réglementé
offrirait à tous particuliers
entreprises et collectivités locales une
meilleure sécurité nous proposons vous
le savez de revenir un monopole public
doté de la capacité d'évaluer les coûts
marginaux à long terme de ces
différentes unités de production ayant
la maîtrise de son programme d'appel on
peut débattre de cette question mais une
chose est sûre sur laquelle nous pouvons
nous mettre d'accord la vie à démontrer
que le principe de concurrence entre
fournisseurs d'électricité n'a rien
apporté de bons usagers quels qu'ils
soient si nous n'opérons pas ce
changement tout ce que vous inventerez
plafonnement du prix du gaz plafonnement
des recettes le fera marchino PPA la
liste est longue
constitueront des rustines mais nos
réglerons rien vous allez sanctuariser
le principe de la prétendue concurrence
libre et non foncé et passez votre temps
à inventer des perpétuels distorsion à
ce principe financée par des fonds
publics ou par des transferts
artificiels on les acteurs entre les
acteurs du marché c'est aberrant ces
coûteux et c'est inefficace nous vous
proposons chers collègues l'occasion de
reprendre la main au Parlement pour
taper du point sur la table de la
négociation européenne comme nous
devrions le faire depuis longtemps sur
le refus de la mise en concurrence des
barrages hydroélectriques notre
proposition est là pour cela vous pouvez
vous en saisir chers collègues
aujourd'hui merci merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant
monsieur Jean-Claude Tissot pour le
groupe socialiste pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout d'abord je
tiens à remercier les auteurs de ces
propositions de résolution qui nous
permettent après avoir débattu des
tarifs réglementés pour les
collectivités en décembre d'aborder une
nouvelle fois les problématiques du
marché européen de l'énergie mon
collègue Franck motoger combien
d'entendre a exprimer les nombreuses
aberrations de ce marché qui bien loin
de réaliser des promesses de réduction
des factures pour les consommateurs
n'aura cervicale à la spéculation et à
la multiplication de fournisseurs
alternatifs il a également insisté sur
la nécessité de considérer l'électricité
comme un bien commun devant tant devant
être décorrélés des logiques du marché
madame la ministre si vos promesses de
restructuration d'EDF aboutissent ne
perdez pas de vue ce principe
fondamental pour nos concitoyens et pour
l'intérêt général pour répondre à la
crise énergétique des textes nationaux
ou européens passent les uns après les
autres mais ne sont que des rustines qui
ne répondent aucunement aux tendances
structurelles et au graves
dysfonctionnement du marché européen de
l'énergie les mesures du gouvernement
restent profondément ancrées dans cette
logique de relâcher et ne permettent que
d'en combler les insuffisances par de
l'argent public comme le rappelle
l'exposé des motifs de cette proposition
de résolution la remise en cause d'une
politique tarifaire décidée par l'État
et l'abandon des coûts de production
comme élément de base de calcul des prix
d'électricité au profit d'un prix formé
sur le marché explique l'impasse dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons actuellement
et pendant ce temps-là les consommateurs
finaux particuliers et professionnels
continuent de subir une explosion de
leurs factures impactant directement
leur budget du quotidien ou leur coût de
production je pense également bien
évidemment au collectivités territoriale
qui depuis de nombreux mois réalise des
efforts importants pour réduire leur
consommation et ainsi tenter de
préserver les budgets votés ainsi quand
le marché devient obsolète pour
reprendre les mots de votre collègue
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire et que les
conséquences sont majeures pour nos
concitoyens il est de deux il est du
devoir du gouvernement et des pouvoirs
publics de réfléchir immédiatement à la
refonte ou à la sortie de ce système
madame la ministre entendait et prenez
en considération les différents textes
de loi et résolutions qui sont examinés
ici dans la chambre haute du parlement
pour que les négociations européennes
avancent enfin à ce sujet les récents
exemples de l'Espagne et du Portugal qui
ont eu l'autorisation de déroger aux
règles européennes pour fixer les prix
de l'énergie en fonction de leur propre
mix énergétique sont particulièrement
intéressants cette mesure permet et on
constate déjà de faire baisser les
factures d'électricité des Espagnols et
des Portugais de 10 à 20%. la
spécificité géographique de ces pays
justifie certainement ses adaptations
mais cette dérogation temporaire prouve
que c'est le marché et les
interconnexions qui tirent le prix vers
le haut alors que notre mix énergétique
se base très fortement sur nos capacités
nucléaires et sur les énergies
renouvelables que nous espérons voir se
multiplier dans un avenir il est de
notre intérêt de il est de notre intérêt
de demander une dérogation similaire
pour pouvoir tirer profit des bénéfices
de nos choix énergétiques pour cela il
est indispensable de pouvoir compter sur
un opérateur énergétique fort
proposant de capacités d'investissement
pourtant les doutes continuer de planer
sur les évolutions futures du groupe EDF
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous dire
où en sont les négociations sur l'avenir
d'EDF est-ce que les dispositions de la
reine va être revue et adapté aux
réalités des coûts de production enfin
nous rejoignons également les auteurs de
cette proposition de résolution sur la
nécessité que les concessions
hydroélectriques ne soient pas soumises
à l'ouverture à la concurrence ces
propositions de résolution que nous
soutiendrons doit donc être entendus
comme un appel pour relancer activement
les négociations européennes sur le
marché d'énergie et il est
particulièrement dommage que la
présidence française du la présidente
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne n'est pas permis d'avancer
sur cet enjeu même sur certains même si
ce même pardon même si certains points
de cette résolution mériteraient d'être
un peu nuancée notamment pour permettre
les négociations avec nos partenaires
européens nous rejoignons pleinement
l'objectif de sortie du système
électrique des mécanismes concurrentiels
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues avant de donner la
parole à madame la ministre je signale à
la Haute Assemblée que j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe les républicains sur l'ensemble
de la résolution donc merci de vous y
préparer madame Agnes ministre de la
transition énergétique vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président tous mes
vœux mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie pour cette proposition
de résolution qui me donne l'opportunité
d'intervenir auprès de vous sur les
enjeux d'organisation et de concurrence
dans le marché électrique il me semble
indispensable de lire cette proposition
de résolution regarde du contexte dans
lequel nous nous trouvons et ces
implications dans le système électrique
français le contexte immédiat c'est tout
d'abord celui d'une crise climatique
d'une part et d'une crise énergétique
sans précédent depuis plus de 40 ans une
crise sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui m'a conduit à
prendre des mesures exceptionnelles pour
passer l'hiver dans les meilleures
conditions plan de sobriété sécurisation
de nos importations et de nos
interconnexions augmentation des marges
de manœuvre sur les moyens de production
d'électricité existant notamment votée
par votre assemblée cet été
je rappelle que la sécurisation de nos
importations elle est également liée au
bon fonctionnement du marché européen de
l'électricité et lorsqu'on se prévaut de
vouloir en sortir nécessairement on pose
la question de ce bon fonctionnement une
crise également sur les prix de marché
puisqu'ils sont passés de 50 euros du
mégawattheure environ en 2020 à plus de
500 euros du mégawattheure au second
semestre dernier avec même un pic à plus
de 1000 euros du mégawattheure au moment
où les clients les consommateurs
anticipés des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en électricité et
intégrer cette prime de risque dans les
coûts nous connaissons tous les effets
de ces hausses historiques pour les
Français les entreprises et les
collectivités locales c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement a pris un engagement très
clair nous ne laisserons tomber personne
et c'est pourquoi nous avons pris des
mesures exceptionnelles pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et la
compétitivité de notre économie bouclier
amortisseurs électricité plafonnement du
prix d'électricité pour les très petites
entreprises qui utilisent une forte
puissance d'électricité baisse de la
fiscalité guichet d'aide aux électro
intensifs et pour financer ces
différentes mesures une contribution sur
les fentes inframarginales prélevées sur
les énergéticiens dont les bénéfices
augmenteraient dans des proportions
importantes du fait précisément de
l'augmentation de ces prix tout cela est
très logique finalement la rente qui
serait créée par cette situation de
marché revient au consommateurs mais ce
contexte appel une réponse systémique et
je vous rejoins monsieur le sénateur gay
sur ce point mais sur ce point seulement
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle je
porte auprès de mes homologues européens
une position forte au nom de la France
celle d'une refonte équilibrée du marché
européen l'électricité cependant je vais
être clair nous ne souhaitons pas sortir
du marché d'électricité européen ne
cédons pas aux fausses bonnes idées car
ce sont toujours celles qui sont les
plus préjudiciables pour notre pays nous
devons préserver les avantages actuels
du marché dans l'intérêt des
consommateurs et de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique le marché de
l'électricité c'est avant tout un marché
qui doit être c'est avant tout un marché
physique ce sont des électrons il doit
être efficace pour éviter les coupures
liées à des déséquilibres entre l'offre
et la demande il n'y a pas de différence
sur un réseau entre un électron espagnol
un électron allemand ou un électron
français en termes physiques je ne parle
pas de bilan carbone et cela n'a rien à
voir avec les voitures qu'elles soient
Ferrari ou Peugeot comme vous le
mentionnez devant dans votre propos
deuxième avantage de ce marché c'est la
capacité à importer exporter
l'électricité de manière juste et avec
un principe de solidarité et lorsque
nous en avons besoin et c'est arrivé
plusieurs fois dans l'année et l'année
dernière et l'année encore dernière on
ne se plaint pas que ce marché
fonctionne finalement pas si mal
troisième avantage la bonne efficacité
afin de donner les bonnes indices
incitation à investir dans la production
d'énergie des carbonées comme ABC notre
consommation énergétique enfin je
souhaite rappeler l'expiration fin 2025
du mécanisme de la reine de régulation
du nucléaire existe ce mécanisme vous le
savez a été central dans notre système
électrique il a joué un rôle important
de protection du consommateur
résidentiel et de maintien de notre
compétitivité industrielle il a permis à
tous les Français d'accéder à
l'électricité nucléaire sur la base de
coûts très compétitif pour autant et on
le sait ce mécanisme présente des
défauts bien
identifiés tout d'abord la concurrence
n'a pas développé les capacités de
production attendues ensuite le prix qui
avait été initialement fixé sur la base
des coûts théoriques de production du
nucléaire n'ont pas évolué avec
l'inflation réduisant de fait les marges
de manœuvre de DF la correction de ces
défauts est un enjeu des réflexions en
cours sur la du marché européen la
Commission européenne a annoncé qu'elle
travaillait désormais dans ce sens et
une proposition législative européenne
est attendue pour le premier semestre
2021 au Conseil des ministres de
l'énergie pour entrer dans le détail de
votre proposition de résolution sur la
production tout d'abord le principal
enjeu auquel nous faisons face
aujourd'hui celui d'augmenter la
production d'énergie des carbonées je
veux bien entendre qu'il faut découpler
l'électricité des énergies fossiles mais
lorsque nous sommes dépendants sur notre
mix énergétique aux deux tiers d'énergie
fossile qui ne sont pas présentes sur
notre territoire il va falloir accepter
la logique de marché ou sinon c'est une
logique de pénurie la production dans ce
cadre nous devons maximiser la
production d'énergie des carbonées avec
la meilleure organisation de marché
qu'elle soit concurrentielle ou plus
régulier en fonction des spécificités
des technologies
pour les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables la concurrence permet de
baisser les coûts de production et de
mettre des porteurs de projets au défi
de produire au coûts dans le champ de
contrainte de service public que nous
appelons dans les appels d'offres cela
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir des projets
de photovoltaïques des projets
d'éoliennes terrestres des projets
d'éoliennes marines qui permettent de
produire de l'électricité à un coût
inférieur à 100 euros du mégawattheure
soit un coût largement compétitif par
rapport au prix du marché pour le
nucléaire la question 60 à 80 pour être
plus précise pour le nucléaire la
question de la concurrence est comme
vous le savez très différentes compte
tenu de l'historique et de la
spécificité du parc nucléaire français
ainsi que du fait qu'il n'y a pas qu'une
technologie de réacteur de fortes
puissances en Europe
qu'il n'y a qu'une technologie pardon je
tiens ici à saluer tous les salariés de
la filière ce sont leurs efforts joint à
ceux de tous les Français dans la
sobriété énergétique qui nous permettent
de réussir le passage de l'hiver et en
toute état de cause je tiens à le redire
ici nous sommes attachés à
l'exploitation par EDF du parc nucléaire
dans une logique intégrée c'est un atout
unique qui est le parc nucléaire
français il n'a pas été construit dans
une logique concurrentielle il doit
jouer dans notre système un rôle
durablement singulier
s'agissant pardon
s'agissant ensuite de l'hydraulique nous
sommes engagés comme vous le savez dans
un contentieux avec la Commission
européenne depuis plusieurs années
puisqu'elle souhaiterait que nous
remettions en concurrence des
concessions hydrauliques et chutes je
tiens à réaffirmer ici que tel n'est pas
notre souhait au regard des enjeux
spécifiques autour de l'eau la
production électrique et son rôle
crucial dans l'équilibre de notre
système électrique d'une part le soutien
laitierge à l'irrigation à Laval et aux
usages d'eau potable vous avez
évidemment entendu dans mon propos les
besoins de l'agriculture et les besoins
d'autres activités qui recouvre à l'eau
ensuite pour ce qui concerne les marchés
de gros de l'électricité le sujet le
plus urgent à traiter et celui de
permettre aux consommateurs et aux
fournisseurs de sécuriser à long terme a
pris l'électricité définie à l'avance et
baisse est basée sur les coûts de
production réelle cela permettrait de
réduire la volatilité des prix facturés
aux clients cela donne de la visibilité
aux producteurs et leur donc de prendre
des risques plusieurs outils existent
déjà pour accorder cette sécurité les
ppachez Power agrement tant mauvais
français que nous poussons déjà pour
toutes les énergies et notamment pour
les énergies renouvelables dans le cadre
du projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables et dont vous
savez qu'ils sont des succès en Europe
les contrats pour différences ensuite
qui sont déjà très répandues pour les
énergies renouvelables et qui
fonctionnent également en France comme à
l'étranger à plus court terme en
revanche les marchés gros ont un rôle
utile pour l'ajustement physique du
marché
reste enfin les marchés de la fourniture
d'énergie qui ont été ouverts à la
concurrence en 2012 et qui je pense sont
le point focal d'attention de votre
discussion de cette discussion plusieurs
grandes questions sur l'opportunité de
cette mise en concurrence peuvent être
posées première question la concurrence
sur ce marché a-t-elle permis de
favoriser le développement de capacités
de production des carbonées le constat
est très mitigé je l'ai déjà dit
a-t-elle contribué à réduire le prix de
l'énergie oui quand il n'y avait pas de
tension sur le marché non quand il y a
eu un choc celui de la crise en Ukraine
et l'utilisation du gaz russe comme arme
de guerre on peut noter en revanche que
la marge dégage g par l'activité de
fournisseur et demeurée relativement
stable contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre ici ou là
a-t-elle contribué à innover dans le
type d'offres proposées aux clients sans
doute oui mais de façon très hétérogène
cette question de la concurrence dans le
marché de détails de l'électricité
renvoie également à celle des trve des
tarifs régulés les Français sont
profondément attachés au principe des
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité le
gouvernement les a défendus
énergiquement dans le précédent
quinquennat devant les juridictions
françaises avec succès et au niveau
européen dans le cadre du paquet énergie
propre il permet de reconnaître le fait
que l'électricité est un bien de
première nécessité pour les ménages et
les très petite entreprise les tarifs
réglementés apportent ainsi une offre
universelle dont peuvent bénéficier tous
les consommateurs sans condition de
ressources ou de solvabilité et ils
apportent une référence tarifaire
utile pour se repérer dans le marché et
comparer les offres nous continuerons à
les défendre que car cela protège les
consommateurs et d'ailleurs je rappelle
que c'est ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui
d'offrir l'électricité au prix le plus
bas d'Europe au ménage et aux très
petites entreprises protéger les
consommateurs c'est s’assurer que son
fournisseur quel qu'il soit prennent ces
responsabilités c'est s'assurer qu'il se
couvre quand il s'engage sur le long
terme qu'il prend des engagements de
production qu'il participe au
déploiement du mix des carbonés dont
nous aurons besoin demain c'est au final
s'assurer que les fournisseurs
anticipent les défis des dix prochaines
années pour ne pas être dépourvu mais
c'est aussi leur garantir des prix qui
couvrent les coûts complets de notre
système énergétique sans marge excessive
ni rentre de situation
cela ouvre la question de savoir si la
future régulation ne devrait pas
introduire un cadre minimum sur la
politique de couverture afin que cette
dernière repose davantage sur des
signaux prix prévisibles à long terme
cela reviendrait à modifier le cadre
concurrentiel dans le marché de la
fourniture d'électricité au bénéfice
d'une plus grande résilience on
maintiendrait certes une concurrence
entre fournisseurs mais ce serait une
concurrence à armes égales où les
fournisseurs seraient tenus de prendre
leur part dans leur production et dans
les charges de service public là où le
gouvernement de 2010 avait fixé des
obligations fortes à EDF sont
véritablement les contrebalancés par de
nouveaux devoirs pour ses concurrents
nous équilibrerons ces droits et ses
devoirs ces quelques éléments me semble
montrer sans aucune ambiguïté qu'une
réponse sur le principe de la
concurrence dans notre système
électrique ne peut être simpliste au
risque d'être grossièrement inexact elle
me semblerait tout autant imparfaite
qu'une doxa idéologique qui revendrit
crée la concurrence pour la concurrence
la question n'est pas tant
concurrence ou pas concurrence c'est
plutôt comment créer le cadre de marché
dans lequel le jeu de la concurrence
permet d'atteindre nos objectifs communs
de politique publique de long terme au
meilleur coût pour la collectivité et
les citoyens c'est bien la feuille de
route que je me suis fixée à la tête de
ce ministère c'est la position que je
défendrai dans les discussions du texte
que proposera la Commission européenne
au premier semestre et c'est pour cela
que je vous invite à ne pas voter cette
PPR je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre nous allons
procéder au vote sur la proposition de
résolution je vous rappelle que la
Conférence des Présidents a décidé que
les interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote je vous rappelle
également que j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
les républicains il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
tu as du scrutin votant 342 exprimer 333
pour la résolution 153 contre la
résolution 180 la résolution n'est pas
adoptée
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance mardi 17 janvier
à 14h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération des procédures
liées à la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires à proximité de
site nucléaires existants et ont
fonctionnement des installations
existantes la séance est levée
[Musique]